a través de estos bosques A menos 30
grados Celsius en invierno una cantidad
récord de clandestinos trata de huir
desde hace meses de los patrulleros
norteamericanos nieve hasta las rodillas
con frecuencia un morral como único
equipaje decenas de adultos pero también
niños son detenidos aquí semanalmente
nunca había visto esas cifras ocurre
todas las noches muchos migrantes que
hemos tenido aquí nos han dicho que no
sabían que él haría que habría hielo en
el suelo y esas serían las condiciones
es muy difícil para nosotros fuerzas del
orden porque no sabemos Quién es quién
ni lo podemos hacer para ayudarlos a
sobrevivir o alcanzar su objetivo creo
que esto debe ser atendido a un nivel
mucho más elevado el fenómeno sorprende
a las autoridades pero también a los
residentes cerca de la frontera mi hijo
estaba arriba en su escondite del lado
canadiense martangamashi y su familia
asisten desde hace A pasos cada vez más
numerosos por su propiedad hacia los
Estados Unidos la primera jornada de
casa unos migrantes pasaron justo por
aquí eran 6 mi hijo estaba sentado aquí
durante la casa Si caminas en línea
recta los Estados Unidos se encuentran a
150 200 metros mi casa se encuentra a
unos 500 metros allá
marthan y su esposa hasta ahora estaban
habituados a ver entrar a los
solicitantes de asilo a Canadá su casa
queda cerca de roxham Road donde según
la agencia de servicios fronterizos
cerca de 40.000 migrantes llegaron de
Estados Unidos en el 2022 Son más
sudamericanos o de África Central los
que pasan para regresar a Estados Unidos
sí principalmente antes veíamos
Estados Unidos hacia acá teníamos sirios
cualquier cantidad de nacionalidades y
ahora es América del Sur o América
Central que pasan de nuevo hacia Estados
Unidos a diferencia de roxanne donde
Canadá incita oficiosamente a los
clandestinos a presentarse para
controlarlos mejor el trayecto del Norte
hacia el sur es más peligroso a veces es
incluso mortal
[Música]
el 23 de diciembre pasado en plena
Tempestad de nieve fritznel Richard
solicitante de asilo en Canadá trató de
regresar a Estados Unidos para reunirse
con su familia
en estado de hipotermia desorientado
este haitiano de 44 años perdió la
comunicación telefónica con su esposa
que lo espera en Florida una patrulla en
helicóptero encontró su cuerpo sin vida
al día siguiente a unos cientos de
metros de la frontera
es cada uno de ustedes y cada una de
ustedes que tienen la esperanza de
encontrar aquí en Canadá o en otro lugar
una mejor vida en Montreal para la
comunidad de migrantes lo que hizo
fritznel Richard se explica por la
impaciencia frente al tiempo de espera
de su proceso de asilo el sueño
canadiense ya no es lo que era el costo
de vida el costo de la vivienda hace que
esas personas no logren vivir después de
un año el señor no había recibido su
permiso de trabajo pero en cuanto al
sueño americano Él pensaba Tal vez sea
mejor en Estados Unidos porque Canadá ya
no es lo que se creía y toman el riesgo
de regresar Y son muchos los que lo
hacen
vivir en la clandestinidad en vez que
como refugiado en Canadá las únicas
cifras disponibles los de las
intercepciones de personas en el costado
norteamericano confirman una nueva
tendencia migratoria
344 arrestos durante el mes de enero
ocho veces más que en el mismo periodo
hace un año antes era una carretera
entre Estados Unidos y Canadá profesora
a menos de 50 kilómetros de la frontera
Amy Moon Castle es especialista en
migraciones y se interesa por este nuevo
flujo de los candidatos al asilo en
Estados Unidos y Canadá tanto para ella
como para los abogados canadienses
especializados en inmigración con los
que hablamos las dificultades en Estados
Unidos Serán las mismas incluso peores
que las bebidas en Canadá
el sistema canadiense en especial Quebec
está bajo tensión
según lo que entiendo a la gente la
tratan bien
pedir un permiso de trabajo
pueden escolarizar a sus hijos
cuentan con seguro médico y todo ello
mientras esperan su audiencia para la
solicitud de asilo
en Estados Unidos no cuentan con esas
ayudas
hay cierta tendencia a criminalizar el
proceso ocurre en Canadá pero menos
seguido
con más de 64.000 solicitudes
registradas en el 2022 por la agencia de
servicios fronterizos Canadá sigue
siendo para la mayoría de los candidatos
al asilo el país más seguro y la última
etapa de su exilio